let's have a look at it together we'll
go one at a time so you can see I
started you off with ones which are
straightforward and then I'll turn the
curve ball at the end to see what you
can make of it let's do the
straightforward first when we have
distance between two points so you watch
it - the distance formula here I have a
look and it being quoted correctly what
do you think looks pretty good right
having much many tens of thousands of
students reviews the distance formula
what do you think that I've seen is the
most common error in quoting the
distance formula any takers
what do you think students tend to mix
up okay so when you have a look at where
the young X's and Y's are an interesting
thing happens in that do you remember we
pointed this out is if you square it
right suppose well let's have a look you
got to take away negative five which
gives you seven right if I did it the
other way around - five sorry negative
five minus two
what do you get new years seven what
happens when you square it if you know
49 isn't it
so like that all is okay I'll tell you
what else I often see do you notice how
these minuses and there's posses in the
formula there's minuses in the brackets
and there's a plus sign joining the
radical so that's what students often
switch those around again which gives
you a totally different haircut it's
like sometimes depending on the question
you might get a negative number
underneath the square root more like a
whole something has gone wrong
can't be done square root of 53 I just
added down with the question it's all of
these when the question doesn't ask you
to approximate like there's no number of
decimal places or significant figures
what's your default awesome just leave
it as asserted that exact by the way
it's missing one thing missing units now
it's totally okay to approximate if you
do that though I would suggest
leave this line like that light helps me
see all you got exactly and then you
price method because then I know you can
do both those skills on just one
right looks good midpoint who agrees so
look okay yeah you can see but I just in
case you I'm struggle to remember it the
formula for the midpoint is what are you
do the XS you add and then you divide by
two you're just taking the average
between these X values and what about
the wipeout yep same thing you are also
averaging out those okay now would you
just put your pen down for a moment you
pick them up and I need to make a really
important note about this third question
okay I'm not going to ask you answer but
has anyone over the last three minutes
worked out an answer for the third one
anyone not okay this category of
question is really important I don't
know how many of you have ever read a
report like a semester report comment or
will soon in the future where it says
something like so-and-so is able to
answer question but lacks conceptual
understanding we're in the employment
rate in fact it's so important I want
you divided conceptual understanding
it's an important phrase and if you've
never read it because like in a report
comment because your task to develop it
my task to help you develop it what this
means is questions wanted to are
categorically different to question
three if you know a formula right and
you can punch them into the formula you
can do questions why don't you and you
can do it somewhat mindlessly can't you
like you don't even necessarily have to
know where this comes from remember by
the way where does the distance will
come from comes from Pythagoras that's
why these squares and square roots do
you need to know that to do the
difference for you Anton yeah so now
once you get this off you go not in the
background matters this question though
a formula on its own going to totally
let you down which is why we're in
trouble
why we're just kind of heating grid
walls you're like I dunno a formula for
gradient what is it anyway right rise
over run which I would say is y2 minus
y1 over x2 minus x1 so there's your eyes
there's run
these are great but you're in trouble
because this thing requires two points
double it and you've only got one so
what do you do now there's lots of
things you can do there lots of things
you can do from what I would suggest is
you think about the concept degree and
what it means
once you please draw with me actually
when you color keeping with me a small
set of axes
up here somewhere in the corner where
you've got a bit of space and then I
want you to draw I'm sure I said back to
this point eight it's a three common one
I'm going to put I'm going to put one
two three nine one so let's call that a
there here this question is different
because it's a setting do you understand
the concept of gradient as opposed to
can you work with the formula of
gradient you can work with these folders
without understanding the concept but
this question you can't do what does
gradient mean when you see it a husk
what did I tell you one of the grading
apart look like remove the cervical I'm
going to give it away for something if
you got an interval right and put this
over here if I say to an interval and it
looked like this what would you describe
about that white line in terms it's
gradient how'd you use words to describe
it
it's going off right that's the first
thing so see how they go from left to
right it is increasing so that tells me
that the gradient must be positive
going up getting bigger okay what else
keep talking about it would you describe
that as shallow or sphere and steep
right
so therefore not only it's a graded
positive but it's also going to be a big
number go something like five or six or
80 or something like that what would you
do if I showed you a line more like this
it's no longer going up is it going down
which means the gradient is money-
not only now if it's kind of gentle
isn't it like it's fall off the edge of
it it just take its time to go down
right so what does that mean Tommy's
negative what else does it mean that's a
small number may top might be negative
like horror a little bit only living
conserving that mother nature ah we're
going to talk to you about like
magnitude so like negative five is I
supposed to say more negative than
negative 1/4 so I'm not even greater
than or lesser there where negative
corner would be greater than negative 5
I'm talking about how big the number is
all right so you've got a picture in
your head what would it look like it's a
wine had this crazy how would you
describe it is upon it when I give so
that means which way is it going it's
going up for sure
it's our half it's not one it's not five
what does that mean when I tell you it's
a pretty gentle isn't it takers and God
kind of like this guy but going up and
then down we can draw that I mean this
is just a rough diagram can you draw
what a grade of a half might look like
and something like that not very steep
so it's going up right
now B has to be somewhere on this line
because that's the gray ha can you see
why I said before there's an infinite
number of solutions to this question why
is that yeah Daniel the toughest is
equal to something that Sutton yes yes
exactly
if I put B somewhere so that when I pop
it into here it gives me is 1 over 2 I'm
fine and I can be anywhere along this
line I happen to know for instance I
wonder if you can work out why see that
point there look at my diagram I did
this reason literally what is that point
it's 1 comma 0 now how did I know it was
going to pass through there you guys
told me right
this is writer one rise over run with
the rise I think that's the mind isn't
it gone up one unit how far is it one
two one two
did that make sense there's my 1 over 2
so that's what in places I could have
put B that would work they could be 1
comma D but where else can I put it tell
me somewhere else I can put 7 failure 7
3 so here's our what is this this is 3
so if you have 4 5 6 7 to receive at 7 3
why does that work
well it wasn't until dawn is it's all
and let's have a look if I go across
what's the one to get over there how far
out the 1 from 3 to 7 that or how far if
I risen is it still half it is and you
can keep going
you can go 6 7 and 3 you go 600 and then
300 they're all going to give you a
heart
you see how this pushes on the contest a
little further that just is a formula
put the numbers in game number out okay
if you never read something that says on
needs to develop conceptual understand
this is what they're talking about
not just substituting in numbers
mindlessly it actually thinking about
what's going on okay